hello everybody and welcome to part 17
of let's play penumbra the Black Plague
actually I've got a graphical error I
don't know what's going on oh wait no
what's going okay we're good we're good
ah [ __ ] it still there all right okay
sounds like there's another cell behind
the wall okay
locked trap door boom Oh too heavy to
lift
Oh impossible let's go let's go bring it
oh just like that
oh so strong so strong oh man is it
annoying oh yeah pushed it with my fist
alright huh huh oh sure you are
Yeah right nothing can destroy me
obviously given that I died like 40
times and still I'm here just proves how
awesome I am not approaching this
correctly okay the most obvious way is
probably not the right one right okay
how's it gonna work it's gonna pry open
the door oh what's this a loose brick
dub better b'doop hey hey through here
pass me that fight man oh yeah I can get
us out smoke a doobie come on we haven't
got much time pass a pipe yeah whatever
okay I trust you random stranger I don't
know okay stay there I'll be back
sure you will Bandon me
okay yeah
I'll get it friend good luck oh yeah
thank you sir
yep thank you thank you so much oh yeah
what now aliens
I'm as great as your that huh huh uh-huh
oh you're welcome
uh yeah whatever who's getting trippy
man shouldn't have in that bad burrito
messing with me okay bring it on bring
it on all hardcore Oh what's a switch
all the obvious answer is not the right
one what do we get
what do we got oh no too obvious oh it's
way too mainstream for me oh who are you
Oh Oh what what oh nothing another burp
nope not even a little bit not even a
little bit off dead end am i Wratten
amazed I'll bring it I'll bring can I
pick that up nope was it don't think I
pretty much oh yeah Oh bring it Oh break
it oh oh yeah come on charge me bro come
at me bro
man you're slow you're slow bro all
right ready Oh what oh what oh oh hey
I'm it damn it alright that's not it
alright let me pull one of these ding
dong
oh hello yeah get it get it man I'll get
it I'll get it
hardcore smash it Raj it I like this
little crap yeah oh yeah thank you
thank you friend oh thank you you didn't
really help me before but whatever okay
yep yep what now dirt isn't necessary
part of life
oh yeah oh I would have killed him you
know hit me one more time but but I'm a
pacifist like that sometimes yeah yeah
they don't even know they don't even
know
AHA so present so where I feel as if I'm
part of something bigger connected to
everything and everyone
oh yeah oh oh so what's this wonder what
would happen it seems so obvious but
boom one oh I see I got you I got you
box gimme oh oh so strong oh this answer
seems way too obvious
oh the trendsetter shouldn't be doing
this what's this what's in here Oh
switch Boop oh there we go
ticky ticky
oh pardon me died oh don't go that way
happened okay
hold hold this well maybe now the door
will stay open hang on wait a minute oh
damn it okay maybe I I it stopped taking
so maybe I do it again I hit the sherbet
okay how that happened and now it's oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah genius
genius level 99 billion I'll get over
there get over it get there we go and
Boop
Oh closed closed what the hell oh oh
damn it Oh No like really oh oh no I
killed this guy what because of that I'm
alive I don't get it I don't get it
oh I don't get it I don't get it
X x marks the spot
okay we got your clue ah
what that what the hell Oh fu man whoa
okay okay all right are you gonna make
me go through it again I think I know
what to do I think I know what to do I'm
super smart all right
think like turn gate okay it's not
thinking like turn gates thinking like
Oh complete the puzzle okay give me that
me give me that okay I'm gonna do this
the door is gonna close and somehow
that's gonna save this guy I don't know
I don't know I don't know okay clicky
kachunk oh that graphical bug is getting
annoying sorry about that I don't know
if that's my computer or if it's just
the game I don't know maybe something
that I just got deal with alright
alright that happened now I can go
forward without the guy died maybe okay
yeah all right Oh certain death oh okay
so what do I do like we are one in the
same what what okay
alright maybe I am going at this wrong
way oh no oh [ __ ] did I get it wrong
again ah got annoying oh no oh no
I was always in here oh oh cool man
oh cool I like it I like it like it a
lot
okay all right cool okay that's me
all right cool so got it okay uh-huh
okay
all right it's trying to teach me some
lessons here odd odd I know that's how
I'm I did mama okay who we got here okay
so now touching that that killed me
before okay let me try it it's probably
supposed to kill me oh no oh yeah off
flowers aw I just need a hug after this
skipping through a field of daisies well
yeah
yep yep I'm the best uh-huh you know
beings such as you selfishness would be
catastrophic
yeah she's gonna be ah ha for this
reason I shall reveal to you that which
I revealed to how ok why is he dead then
what did why did he have to die if you
showed him the truth I don't know I
don't know guys I came here to this
place oh ok before was even outright a
hoss beyonds came and went
mankind appeared around me ok turban gay
twisted in harmony for much time I lying
dormant within what you refer as in
factor ok
or marriage unprotected they did not
benefit changed uh-huh oh yeah so many
crime so powerful without the
intelligence to answer that oh I am so
smart and powerful you don't even know
man you don't even know ya don't even
know what's this it's all this oh hey
turn about a community somehow it
becomes more dangerous uh-huh whoa
yah yah the armory creator dispenser to
find me and silence me ah
they tore open my rustic all with their
bare hands said about destroy no no and
I with no form of Defense was forced to
attack huh huh huh that sounds about
right
how I would describe myself let's see
right actually I'm gonna cut it right
here but I'm not gonna stop playing so
thank you all for watching this has been
part 16 of let's play penumbra um part
17 oh I'm so stupid
alright anyway I'll see you next time
bye bye